Being a dairy farmer is really hard.
There're not as many young people wanting to become farmers.
A man from Sainsbury's, he buys their milk,...
...saw how tough it was.
So, he got over 300 farmers together to see how he could help.
They had lots of great ideas.
A new way to trim our toenails.
How to use less electricity.
The Sainsbury's man was amazed and got lots of people together...
...to help bring their ideas to life.
That was six years ago.
Now most cows are much happier and making lots more milk.
Sainsbury's got our farmers a really good price for it, so they're happy.
Now all their kids want to be farmers too.
So, we'll have lots of lovely British milk for ages.
Sainsbury's.
You're welcome at the barn anytime.